by reading
this document as chair of division two
of the house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
division two
and we are looking today at the
uh ways and means
um yeah
ways ways and means uh
things thank you my mind went blank as
well as
going through some issues in the draft
hb2
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and
rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should email lba
underscore fiscal at leg
dot dot
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also
state whether there is anyone in the
room with you
during this meeting which is required
under
the right to know law representative
lynn
if you would call the role thank you
madam chair
um representative bucco uh yes thank you
i'm present i'm at home in conway and
there's no one else in the house
representative danielson is not here
representative heath
miry heath here in manchester in my home
and i'm home alone
uh i've uh bob lynn i'm uh here present
in my home in
manchester my wife is here but is not
present in the room and my son
should be landing in tel aviv just about
now
he finally got off uh
representative murray good morning kate
murray here in newcastle my husband at
the moment is in the kitchen doing
dishes
then he will be heading down to the
basement
representative petrie right i'm here in
farmington
uh i'm with the dog and the wife again
they're roaming around in a few rats
all right thank you representative
umberger
yes good morning everyone i am at my
home in kearsarge
my husband is uh wandering around
someplace in the house
otherwise i'm alone
right thank you that's the role
i think you're muted representative
you're muted
yes i'm sorry uh you were going to go
through
um the revenues that um
ways and means is projecting for um
2022 and 23
and to give us sort of an idea as
to um where we stand
and um the differences i guess between
what the governor is recommending
and what we passed on the house floor
on thursday of last week
so i hope everyone received the email
and the information that uh
mickey sent it was three pages so it's
not
a great deal but we're going to look at
education
trust fund the highway fund
and hb2
uh fish and game basically was the same
as the governor's budget
so we really have no um
need to go through that
with uh today so um
anyhow i'll turn it over to uh mr
landrigan
and if you have questions as we're going
through
please just um raise your hand and we'll
call on you so mickey if you would go
ahead please
sure do you have a preference where we
start representative it doesn't
it doesn't matter so what's probably
going to happen for a big picture
um you know if we want to talk general
and education
combined surplus statement mike kane is
going to be working on that
and we'll do something as a full
committee likely at some point soon
to go over that today we can discuss and
i've got documents here for you that
kind of break out just the education
trust fund because that usually falls
just on division two
as well as the highway fund and then
i did pluck um some of the subject
matter from the
house bill 2 the trailer built draft
that we got a couple weeks ago
um we'll speak more about that when we
get to us so
maybe right now we'll start with um
we'll start with the education trust
fund document
and um just a reminder this these
documents are online
on our budget document page in the
division 2 specific page so
if the public is looking for them they
are available online right now
so i'll share a screen here
all right so can you can you all see
this document
mickey can you expand that a little bit
yep
i can uh kind of zoom in and we'll work
our way down
is that that work
so this format should be pretty familiar
to everybody it's essentially just that
that basic surplus statement type look
starting with the beginning balance of
fiscal 21
uh and ending with what the projected
balance would be based on these budget
components at the end of fiscal 23. so
for the education trust fund starting
pretty
close to zero we're going to start with
a deficit balance of 3.2 million to
begin this fiscal year that we're
currently in
um we've plugged in the house based
revenues
up top um and
the adjustments as well starting here on
line 15 through 21
as you know combined education and uh
highway fun excuse me education and
general fund the
revenues were about 80 million dollars
less
the house weighs and means in the house
adopted revenues than um
uh the governors and the breakout of
that is approximately 50 million of it
was in the education trust fund and 30
was attributable to the general fund so
the base revenues
and there is a complicated split with
some of these
some of these business taxes for
instance get split between the general
fund and education trust fund
it's not an across the board for each
revenue source if at a later time we
wanted to dive into that
we could i do have a document i could
send all of you just so at least you
have a reference if you're curious which
revenue source and how it gets split
i'll send that to the committee so
you've got that on hand
that would that would be helpful okay uh
mickey are the um the business profit
and the bet are those based on the
governor's reductions
or are they based on current
law that is a good question so when we
talk about base revenues
those are current law so everything from
line
4 to 12 these are all revenue estimates
based on current law
if we jump down to line 16
or it's really 17 and 18
19 20 these are the adjustments
necessary
for the proposed changes in the taxes
that we should see in house bill 2 when
we get it
thank you yep so um
so just for quick reference the revenue
adjustments
that are in the governor's recommended
budget now total about 18 million
dollars over the biennium
so i'm going to start right at the
beginning we'll just flow right through
this entire document
so starting with our negative 3.2
million dollar balance
we're going to take our base revenues
the folks who have been on division two
in the past will remember
in the last budget there was a pretty
significant surplus in the education
trust fund
and one of the decisions made by budget
writers at the time
was to allocate 62 and a half million
dollars
in fiscal 19 put it aside in a
restricted account
within the education trust fund knowing
it was going to be spent
as part of that one-time education
revenue or excuse me education fund
grants in fiscal 21.
so this line 16 when you see the 62.5
million
additional uh designated for education
aid
that's really just using that money
that's been sitting set aside for this
year
and i'm just going to skip down if you
look at line 27 you'll see the
expenditure of it so the
it's really a net zero what's going on
this year that was revenue
that was collected a couple years ago
and set aside to be spent this year
so the only revenue adjustment that we
have for fiscal 21
is just that 62.5
million make made available from that
designated pond
so all told base revenues and that 62.5
million dollars is an anticipated
addition of
1.1 billion dollars in fiscal 21 to the
education trust fund
so spending appropriations we've got
adequacy charter schools
the other state aid programs school
building aid
special ed aid we'll get into those this
current budget was the first time those
other state programs were pulled into
the education trust fund
and this was also something that budget
writers recognized last year as with the
surplus in the education trust fund this
was an opportunity to fund those
programs
with it rather than with general fund
dollars
so the numbers that you see here
starting with lines 26 through 33
for all three years um this is what's
appropriated so this is what's in house
bill 1
or house bill 3 technically now for
fiscal 21 because we had house bill 3
and 4
this year and then looking ahead at 22
fiscal 22 and fiscal 23
these are the appropriation levels at
the governor's recommended budget so
those are plugged in there now so you
know your starting point
as a division obviously as you make
changes to any line items in these
in this fund we would adjust the surplus
statement accordingly
uh mickey uh mary has uh representative
heath has a question
thank you madam chair um mickey um
these are a done deal no
deductions can be made for this this is
already
in statute so this is stays as is am i
correct
for fiscal 21 yes yep yep so
um first so i i don't know if the
governor's house bill two
i didn't really see anything in the
draft i'm not sure because i i'd have to
double check but i believe we did for
the biennium only
that ended this year so if the idea is
to continue
funding these programs from the
education trust fund
a house bill 2 section will be necessary
if for whatever reason that's not in the
bill as introduced
i would consider that like a technical
thing that the division division 2 could
square up
we could take care of that thank you
so as i mentioned all of these programs
this is these amounts here in fiscal 21
um represent what was appropriated in
house bill 3.
on line 35 we we generally don't budget
an education trust fund lapse so when we
set
um when we set the budget for every two
years for the education trust fund
we appropriate at a level that we think
are the best estimates of what is the
actual expenditure going to be
so there's no anticipated laps because
really if everything goes well you're
going to spend it pretty close to what
you
what you expected we have learned
that in fiscal 21 there's going to be
about a 16.4 million dollar
laps on expended appropriations and as
you know these programs
specifically this is related to adequacy
and charter schools
um as enrollments change obviously the
amount that the state pays changes
so between uh adequacy charter schools
and there might be a little bit based on
the uh school building aid
appropriation that was put out there's
gonna be 16.4 million dollars of
unexpected
appropriations this year so that's why
you see that represented
as a positive here versus the
appropriations negative so that's
essentially going to help your bottom
line
so all told on line 38 you'll see that
the current year balance for the
education trust fund is
3.1 million which means revenues over
anticipated expenditures uh positive 3.1
when you net that against our starting
balance of
negative 3.2 it gets to a 98 000
deficit and what is done generally
is the comptroller's office will
true up the education trust fund in the
case of a deficit
with a general fund transfer so this
budget picture includes a 98 000
transfer
from general funds to um
get to an ending balance in the
education trust fund of zero dollars
i'll pause there to see if we have any
questions
mickey
so special education tuition
transportation school building aid
were all put in
the education trust fund in 18.
uh uh 20 and 21. so it was the 19th
session yeah
okay yeah yeah 19. okay so
unl if those are not currently
continued in hb2
then those in fact could come out of
there is that what you're suggesting
it's up to you there's no there's
nothing outside of statutory change that
decides how those programs are paid
so if the committee and when you develop
a budget you would like
those programs to be general funded we
can just switch the appropriation and
the budget to general fund and make sure
this
the um the statute ties to that decision
or vice versa if you want to have
everything in the education trust fund
or even a combination of you know so
as being responsible for house bill 1
and 2 you've got the flexibility to do
what you want with those programs the
only
above statute if you will um restriction
on anything here is lottery revenue
so way up top that 120 million 120 527
by the constitution that revenue needs
to go to schools so
everything else my understanding would
be
up to you in house bill 2 and house bill
1 how you want to
position your budget
representative heath you had a question
more of a comment
um in the last budget cycle the reason
why
we took special ed tnt and school
building aid
and brought it into the trust was
because we had
those funds and then we could um release
general fund funds um to give more
flexibility to some of the other
divisions
but it worked out well because it's it's
education oriented so it worked within
the context of the law
so um i thought it was a good move at
the time
and um made good use of the funds thank
you
representative murray yeah thank you
this is kind of a dumb question
uh mickey what are the numbers that you
use to get the 98 million or is it 98
000.
what are those two lines so the 98 000
just represents the amount needed from
the general fund
to finish on that next line of zero so
which lines did you use to get that is
that
so it's essentially your beginning
balance so the 3.207
it's a negative but then you had a
positive year the net of those two
amounts
is 98 000 can you give me the line
numbers
it's a line one and
38 shouldn't that to 98 000.
thank you
representative bucco
yes thank you madam chair um mickey i
had a i had a phone call i had to take
the minute you started this so let me i
just want to make sure that i
understand where we're going here you
started with um
revenues you started with fiscal year 21
and you went through revenues
and then i and then appropriate
and then um revenue revenue adjustments
and then appropriations i came in
sometimes someplace in within
appropriations that
did i miss anything that i need to know
um i was just discussing representative
bucco that
so once we've got our revenues estimated
for the year we're gonna
apply the appropriations that were made
these rows 26
through 33 are what was actually
budgeted
and then on line 35 we anticipate this
year 16.4 million of it
won't will lapse won't be spent just
because of the actual data of students
being
uh in the formulas for the aid programs
which gets you down to a
positive year of 3.109 million
when you apply that to the negative
starting position we still need 98 000
from the general fund to get to a zero
balance very good thank you
so i'll move on to fiscal 22 and 23
which is our upcoming biennium
so as i mentioned the 98 000 would bring
the
balance of the fund to zero so we're
going to start fiscal 22 with a zero
balance
now we're going to apply our base
revenues just over a billion dollars
and we're gonna now see these revenue
adjustments
based on the governor's proposed changes
that we will see in house bill
2. um in fiscal
20 uh two in total it's 5.6 million
dollars
which gets your net available revenues
estimated for fiscal 22 in the education
trust fund to
one 1.066 billion dollars
moving on to the appropriations so this
document now just has plugged in
what you see in the governor's budget
bill the recommended budget
so adequacy set at 940 million charter
schools
just under 47 million the low and
moderate income
uh homeowners program 800 000 a year
special education aid and tuition and
transportation set at the same levels as
last year
and then for school building aid the
amount funded my understanding is just
the tail payments and there was no
funding in there for new traditional
school building aid projects
these programs everything i just
mentioned with the exception of the low
and moderate
um homeowners program um the department
will be in with us
on um a wednesday to discuss these in
more detail so
there was a slight tweak proposed
adequacy
related to free and reduced lunch
enrollments we'll see that in house bill
2.
and then i don't think there was any law
changes relative to the other programs
but the department will be able to walk
us through
where those numbers are how they were
derived and what they will serve what
the
uh the aid going out to the districts
uh mickey oh i see lots of hands up okay
mary you're you seem to be at the top of
the screen so go ahead
thank you oh it was my phone i'm sorry
um
uh you know what why don't you take
somebody else and let my phone
[Music]
okay representative lynn
please thank you madam chair um mickey
can i just ask him
um i see on line 27
that there is no appropriation or
proposed appropriation
for the next two fiscal years
for additional education aid can you
just
kind of explain to me what that what
that
was and why it's not being proposed now
what i'm not sure i understand
sure um we'll get way more into the
education funding formula
probably wednesday morning definitely
wednesday morning but essentially what
happened was
budget writers in the last biennium
set the education funding payments in
fiscal 21
to also include uh fiscal capacity
disparity aid as well as some enhanced
aid relative to free and reduced lunch
student populations um that was
legislated to repeal
uh june 30 of this year
so that was intended that was put in law
just to apply for one year
um all right you know can i have a
follow-up sure
certainly okay thank you you know just
just one question
am i understanding from what you just
said then that there is already
in the in line 26 the adequate education
aid
there is already some adjustment
for free and reduced lunch is that
correct that's correct
and rather than yep rather than it being
a new aid component
it's just going to be a requirement for
the department of education to use a
different adma
figure when calculating regular adequacy
so
um i maybe could have broken
some of that portion out the the amount
attributable to doing that on this line
or maybe created another row but
we can work with the committee and i'll
work with the department and we can
break out the aid components for all
three years if that's useful for the
committee as we move forward
thank you
so the housing oh sorry
oh thank you and i apologize for my
phone ringing my granddaughter is sick
in florida and she's
upset um my question is mickey
um and i think probably you just said
you were going to do this
can you give us um the amount of money
that we
appropriate appropriated for
2021 minus disparity
the special money that was put in and
the total amount that in the governor's
budget that's been budgeted
um could is that any place that we can
look at or could you do that
that's essentially row 26 on this
document
so the additional disparity in frame
reduced lunch
is included on row 27. okay perfect
thank you
but like i said we're gonna dive way
into this on wednesday with the
department and they'll
you know i'll reach out to them ahead of
time just so we've got all this on hand
for wednesday
thank you representative
uh yes thank you uh so mickey i guess
this is
a related question but on line 28 shows
that
for the current year it's 1 billion 24
million for
um adequate education
and then and then the 939 million and
the 946 million for 22 and 23 represents
about a 70 million dollar uh what
cut from the the 21
the 1 billion from 21 is that about
right
uh i mean yes that's the difference
between the two years
um the governor funded essentially the
ed funding at the current law
with just a little bit of a tweak to the
adm formula
um so if you want to look at total
dollars you can see the decrease from
year to year
there's also quite a bit going on with
enrollments too and you've heard that
testimony
um just with what's going on with the
anti the
projected adms for this coming year
which was used as a base for calculating
these amounts for 22 and 23
um but again we're we're going to get
way more into this wednesday
and but that's essentially what's going
on with that
thank you representative petrie
yeah thank you madam chair uh
on the uh the hr 11 the ways and means
estimates how do that how does that
reconcile what we have here
so um going way up to
the base revenues so in the
education trust and this document here
representative is just education trust
fund
these these base revenues are about
50 million less than the governor's base
revenues so this document here
and if i jump over to the governor's
so this is the governor's surplus
statement so the governor had
anticipated the education trust fund
ending with a positive balance of 32
32.2 million dollars at the end of
fiscal 23. right now with the house's
revenues plugged in and everything else
kept the same mind you
it's anticipated to be about an 18
million dollar need for general fund
support
so versus 32.2 plus or 18
negative that's about your 50 million
dollar difference in revenues
there there's also a difference in the
those house
revenues on the general fund side i
don't have that on here that's about
another 30 million or close to
and like i said mr kane in our office is
probably going to do something higher
level with a combined general education
surplus picture for the committee
at some point soon
representative heath thank you madam
chair just one more question i'm sorry
is it within our authority school
districts across the state are
just beside themselves because of the
october one um
count student counts for in relation to
um student counts and then the freedom
reduced lunch because
they're not coming in at all is it
within
our authority to hold them harmless
with um school numbers from 2020
instead of the 21 school year
uh yes i mean that that's you can direct
through legislation what you want the
department of education to use either
for
um inputs or just a flat out you know
it's
referred to as a whole harmless
sometimes just a flat funding at a
dollar level
we can legislate anything in house bill
2 related to
how much gets paid for education funding
thank you
the only thing about that and i would
defer to the department is
challenges relative to timing and local
budgets and all that you know and how
the state aid works so
the technical aspect of it is another
thing but um
from a state perspective to expend those
dollars yes that's that's in the context
of one and two the house bill one and
two
so follow up madam chair yes go ahead
please
so the only way that we could help
because they're doing their budgets
basically right now in town meetings and
all of that
so the only way that we actually the
finance committee could actually
well maybe there isn't a way we could
actually help them it would have to be a
bill
that was sent to us like the one that's
coming from the senate
that we would have to move along quickly
um
and get authorized and then get that
over to the governor's desk that's the
only way that
actually we could help them with that
for the the fiscal year that they need
the help with
um possibly i i mean i i the timeline of
house bill one and two you're talking
end of june effective for one july
right so if the idea would be to
authorize that money
officially sooner than that so districts
could plan and budget
yeah you would need a piece of
legislation sooner than the timeline of
the budget
thank you but actually um
i if if in fact that went
into hb2 even though
the school district may not
know what they're getting they could in
fact
just simply accept that money
it doesn't have to be done now
you know when when uh when the
distribution is made
in uh the three times a year
that um they they accept the money it's
not
it's not hard and fast as to um
what we what we put in and i would
personally prefer that whatever occurs
would be in hb2 and
that um i would think that uh
you know we have to we have to send a
balanced budget over to the senate
and so uh if we decide to put
more money into adequate education aid
then we have to take it from someplace
else within the um
education trust fund so it's going to be
a balancing act
for us as to what
what do we want to support
and it may be best at this
point to
obviously hear what doe has to say but
to leave whatever the adequate education
is and then press for the senate
to increase it based on their
projections
of what's coming i i mean i was
i was flabbergasted that
this is what the ways and means
committee
unanimously put forward to us
so it's you know it's obviously
what you know it's like any compromise
is what you can get through and
so i was not part of the ways and means
discussion so i don't
have any idea who did what to whom but
uh
but that's that's just my feeling um
at this point
uh mickey i do want to ask um
about this 62-5 was that
targeted to something special yep
so that was the initial estimates of the
time of the total related to
the fiscal capacity disparity aid and
the additional free and reduced lunch so
the one-time money
that was the estimate of what it was
going to be was 62-5 so that's why that
was put aside two years ago with the
anticipation that was going to be the
amount paid out in
21 however that's
contributing to some of that 16.4
million laps just because of what
happened with
enrollments and you know we make
estimates two years out for head funding
which is difficult so it ended up being
a little bit
less than 625 all told which is why some
of that was freed up
in that 62. 16.4 million laps
okay so that lapse stays within the
education trust fund is that correct
correct yep that's entirely that
restricted money it said any unexpended
portion would go back to the education
trust fund that's the way it was written
in house bill 2.
okay now i know we're going to get into
the hb2 stuff
but the governor did say
that we would use the free and reduced
lunch numbers from
was it 2019
uh yeah i think i'm going to hold off on
speaking to the details of house bill 2
because
like like you all i think i've seen an
early draft not sure what's going to
change but i can tell you the the
numbers and the backup to calculating
those numbers
made a an adjustment to the free reduced
lunch numbers to bring them up
i'm not sure it was entirely back to
what the numbers were in fiscal 20 i
think there's a formula that's going to
be proposed
that's going to bring those numbers up
and we'll get into that
definitely when we get house bill 2 but
hopefully we can get into that with more
detail wednesday as well with the
department
i just don't want to say it is one way
and then we get house bill 2 and it's
slightly different than that you know
that's that's my whole concern
yeah i i understand that um
okay so um
all right let's go on to uh 23
well 22 and 23 which are
which are not looking too good
so to finish up fiscal 22 here if you
look at line 34
um the governor's budget proposes
transferring 15 million dollars a year
to the public school infrastructure fund
all of you may be familiar with this it
was in somewhat of a wind down mode
it was funded with some state surplus
dollars a couple of times over the years
provided many grants across the state to
school districts
and the governor's budget proposes 15
million dollars in each fiscal 22 and 23
to that fund so taking into
consideration all the revenues revenue
adjustments and anticipated expenditures
the current year balance for fiscal 22
ends with a 2.6 million
deficit which would require on line 40
you see a transfer in
from the general fund of 2.6 million
dollars to get back to a zero
uh balance again so i put on the very
bottom here accumulative general fund
support
so just so you know so remember we took
we needed 98 000
last year add the 2.6 million dollars
this year now we're up to 2.7 this
budget proposal
to this point needs 2.7 million dollars
from the general fund to balance the
education trust fund
not a whole lot difference 22 or excuse
me 23 is essentially the same story as
22.
we've got your base revenues you've got
your revenue adjustments
second year of these tax changes have a
little bit bigger of an impact
so you see the adjustments on line 22 go
from 5.6 million negative
last year to 12 million dollars in
fiscal 23.
to get to a 10.06 billion
total revenue and 23. here we've got our
um education funding programs
the 15 million dollars this year to this
public school infrastructure fund
fiscal 23 ends with a negative balance
of close to 16 million dollars
transfer in that from the general fund
back to a zero balance
add that nearly 16 to the previous 2.7
all told the general fund would chip in
18 and a half million dollars
in this budget proposal to balance the
education trust fund
and that's where we're at that's your
starting point essentially
in division two when it comes to
education trust fund
okay i don't like that starting point
representative murray
thank you so in the revenues with the
changes to
bet and all that
we're losing about 61 million dollars
and then 67 million dollars in revenues
from 21 to 22 22 to 23 i'm looking at
line 23. so the only thing there is i
would caution is
that 62 and a half million dollars
wasn't really revenue of fiscal 21
that was just that set aside money that
we pulled in to spend in 21.
so if you back out that 62 and a half
million dollars on line 16
your revenues actually are really flat
they you know
if you just look at your base revenue in
because it'll back it won't include that
625 it's 1.065 billion
and then if we jump down here after
adjustments you're almost
right on the money i see you know so
it's pretty flat if you just
ignore that set-aside money that we
pulled back in so there's a six million
from 22 to 23.
uh correct correct okay thanks
are there any other questions on
education trust fund representative lin
yes thank you madam chair um mickey i
wonder i i i want to make sure that i'm
understanding something that the
and maybe maybe this is something we're
going to talk about
more on wednesday but the um
the projections for um
uh the um the transfers to the
uh starting line uh 25 those projections
is i know that i think representative
heath mates
was concerned about using the october
i guess last year numbers first for
student enrollments and i
i i guess what i'm i i guess i wanted to
explore that a little bit more
um i i'm not sure i understand what the
problem is with using those numbers and
and if if part of the problem is that
you know that was during the sort of
covid
during the middle of covid i guess what
i'm wondering is
that you know to the extent that those
reflect a a
um a drop in student population
is it out of line with the drop
that i as i understand it has been going
on for several years in other words is
there
a precipitous drop last year that
um you know that is much higher than it
was
from uh from the it going back you know
several bienniums
that's a good question um total
enrollments have been
on the decline which is naturally since
ed funding is a per capita program it
has naturally just decreased the total
adequacy grants statewide um
from what the department put out there
for estimates for this coming year were
significantly less than that trend
and they were pandemic related both in
base
total number of students and then as
well for
free and reduced lunch populations so
you may remember i think
commissioner edelblut was speaking to
this
last week with us um you know this
trying to get
students who are eligible for free and
reduced lunch population identified as
so
because that's what drives the state
formula so um
lunch was provided meals were provided
in my understanding to all students
regardless of
qualification in that regard so it
really sent a decline in the number of
students who were identified as eligible
for free and reduced lunch meals which
that's the data set that the department
uses for calculating grants and that's
they're bound by that in law which is
why there's been a couple bills this
session to
modify the data set that the department
of education would use to calculate
grants for the next two years
you know recognizing that some of the
data may
have been impacted because of the
pandemic
thank you
representative heath you have a question
yes just to comment um
to um respond also to representative
lynn
all those dollars and and um the
commissioner edelblut talked a little
bit about this too
those numbers that have been driven
and the the lower number uh based
directly
due to the pandemic have a huge
impact all across the board because not
only does it
impact the amount of money that school
districts get it ultimately
impacts greatly the number of federal
funds that we get new hampshire already
gets small state minimums
but the the money that comes into
new hampshire is driven by those free
and reduced
numbers so it's critical how we look at
those and
that's why getting those numbers to
what they really are is critically
important for our state of new hampshire
okay are there any other questions
on the education trust fund
at this point
okay mickey you have
provided us with a lot of food for
thought here
and uh if this isn't bad enough
i'm really excited to go to the
highway fund and this one is going to be
really difficult for us because
so much money is
goes to uh goes to safety
and so we have to make sure as we're
looking through this
that we're able to balance what
safety uses and what
highway uses so i will let you start
mickey
all right so similar format
to the education trust fund document so
all this should flow
um in the same way so i'm going to
go through it a little bit quicker but
raise your hand stop me interrupt me if
i'm going too fast
so house-based revenue estimates when it
comes to the highway fund we're talking
unrestricted road toll which is also
referred to as the gas tax
and then all your unrestricted revenue
relative to motor vehicle fees and fines
all collected by safety um
these estimates my understanding are the
agency estimates that were adopted by
house ways and means
uh which were over the three years
about six million dollars 6.2 i believe
less than the governor's estimates
so that's essentially your your um
your nexus from where the governor's
budget was to where you're starting
so starting with fiscal 21
we started with a budgetary balance of
nearly 64 million dollars
ways and means estimates are 238 million
for the year then if you recall
and and folks who have been on the
division before remember this
the department of safety has highway
fund appropriations in two different
ways
really one of them is just straight
highway funds which most of them
reside in the division of state police
when you pull up their budget you will
see
highway funds and it's clear in the
division of motor vehicles
um there's all those accounts most of
those accounts are funded with
agency income which is really the
cost related to collecting and
administering highway
fund revenue and this is something
that's in statute and in the
constitution
that directs the department of safety to
net off the cost that it takes them to
collect
the revenues from these different
sources and then remit the difference to
the highway fund
so the revenue adjustments that we have
here on line 10
this is how much the department of
safety is
appropriated in the areas of cost of
collecting and administering
highway fund revenue
we assume they're not going to spend
every nickel that we appropriate in the
budget so that we we
account for a lapse there on line 12 is
your net
impact of essentially the division of
motor vehicle and some indirect costs at
the department
the costs associated with collecting and
administering highway fund revenue so
it's about 30 million dollars a year
so we take this 30 million dollars off
the the gross revenue of the
238.3 gets to about 208 million dollars
of net revenue to the highway fund in
fiscal 21.
everyone's still with me on that because
cost of collections can be a little
tricky okay appropriations
transfers
three departments in the current budget
have direct highway fund appropriations
department of transportation department
of safety and then the judicial branch
transportation is the lion's share of it
most of it resides in operations
and local aid in the the block grant
line
department of safety most of that like i
said is in state police
and we can get breakdowns and you've
actually got some of the breakdowns and
some of the documents that agencies have
given you as far as specifics in the
governor's recommended budget
as far as which divisions and accounting
units that they're budgeted in
and then judicial branch has for
before my time always had a two million
dollar
highway fund appropriation to subsidize
their general fund budget and it's
always been the same amount
i think the nexus is they adjudicate
motor vehicle
um traffic related cases so the highway
fund supports the judicial branch and
that's the two million dollars there you
see on line 19.
on line 21 the governor's recommended
budget
assumed that in fiscal 21 that there
would be
uh a nine million dollar need for the
department of transportation relative to
winter maintenance to pull from the
highway fund surplus
to date only four and a half million has
been
brought through fiscal and approved the
remaining 4.5 million
i think is just anticipating they could
need more by the end of this year
so this could be something that we would
want to monitor
for the next couple of months because if
it's deemed that
they don't come back for another draw
the winter just we have spring tomorrow
and it's great
or you know maybe they need more than
nine
i'd say the number on line 21 is a fluid
number at this point so we'll monitor
that to see
how much more or less the department
will need to fund winter operations for
the rest of this year
we've got on line 22 this is merely just
an accounting
action related to some revenue that
you know it gets dispersed other funds
mostly related to the
unrefunded road toll so this is like the
gas tax that folks pay for fuel that
goes into their
boat or lawnmower is my understanding so
there's credit back for the tax on that
so this this line 22
is really just an accounting uh line
and then just like the other funds on
line 23 we assume elapse
if you see why uh fiscal 21
is much higher than 22 and 23. and you
heard some of this when the department
was in
some of their spending was down there
was some direction to limit some
spending a little bit for fiscal 21
my understanding is a lot of work has
gone into these lapse numbers and
formulating what they are
i think if you wanted to explore those
more with the department they could
speak
more to them but i think at this point
the lapse is at a place that the
governor's office and the departments
are comfortable with but it's certainly
something you can
discuss with them if you'd like to so
taking those
adjustments off of the 266 million
dollar appropriation from
the operating budget gets down to a 248
million dollar net draw
and if you remember our revenue this
year was only 208
which means in fiscal 20 um 21 there's a
negative
nearly 40 million dollars and that would
essentially come from that carry forward
balance that we started the year with
highway fund we try to balance on a gap
basis so
we recognize at the end of every fiscal
year there's some payables some
liabilities some accounting
adjustments that need to be made these
numbers came from the comptroller's
office
and i don't really see much of a need to
explore those further we can if you'd
like we can we can uh
we can dive into those usually we don't
so once you take into consideration gap
adjustments
this year is anticipated and with a
negative balance
do you have questions at this point or
can i want to move on
uh mickey
with a
with a negative balance
what's the what's the overall effect of
that
yeah yeah
and it's one i've asked before too um
essentially there's i think one of the
biggest concerns is that it could just
affect bond ratings you know that the
fund is
in a negative position you know on an
accrual basis
um i think if i shared anything more
than that it would be
not super informed so if that is
something we want to explore
we should reach out to the comptroller's
office
and and maybe get an opinion from them
and just kind of an explanation of
really what does that mean
if we end the fund with a budgetary
surplus but a gap
deficit what does that mean you know
what's the impact
um and i and i think that's appropriate
to to explore
yes i i i certainly would appreciate you
doing that mickey
uh let's see uh representative bucco
i think you had a question yes thank you
i think you just asked it but i i was
just wanted to clarify for my own
um what just what the estimated gap
adjustment is
because it seems it's it's 27 million
it's pretty large
most of it is just i think accounts
payable it's just
liabilities on the books at the at june
30 that that the highway fund has
future expenditures related to um
i mean if if for the committee's uh
information if we did want to dive into
the you know the gap adjustment and the
gap balance i i think we could
i could reach out to the comptroller's
office like i said we can get get some
more information on that
thank you
lynn you have a question
yes uh thank you madam chair uh mickey i
i guess though
um mine is sort of a follow-up maybe to
representative buccos um
i understand i think i understand the
the
27 million dollar gap adjustment
but what i'm not sure i understand then
is
when if if the if there's a deficit
of the 3 million 156 at the end of
fiscal 21
when i when you go to fiscal 22 you
don't start with that number but you
start with the 23 844
so i'm not i'm not quite sure i
understand
you know and then the same thing in for
from 22 to 23
um it's uh i think so could you just
explain that
sure uh so the gap adjustment is
something that is for an account
presentation like a fun presentation
from an accounting standard point of
view
but it reverses when you start the next
year so there's like a reversing
entry that uh
i'm getting into deep deep accounting
that we usually don't do with um
with finance committee but essentially
that is
a snapshot in time representative that
as of june 30
fiscal 21 this is the state of the
highway fund but that gap entry would
reverse because there's an expectation
you're going to be making those payments
and all those liabilities are part of
your budget that next year
so it's really just to show the state of
the highway fund that yes we have 23
million dollars in the bank
but we have 27 million dollars in bills
outstanding
we only carry the budgetary balance
forward because we assume those 27
million dollars in bills are going to be
paid in that next year we're already
paying for them here
um i'm probably not explaining this all
really well and it is a confusing thing
um but if if like i said i don't think
you would harm because i
i don't think we've done it in my time
with division two which is pushing a
decade now
um just kind of hearing from the
comptroller perhaps or
even the director of finance maria dot
will be able to walk the division
through
the you know financial statements
presentation of the highway fund and
that's really what we're talking here
from a budgetary point of view if you
only cared about money in the bank
it's this line okay no it's the
budgetary balance line but
the the precedent has always been to try
to balance the highway fund
on a gap on an accrual basis gap basis
too
thank you obviously that makes perfect
sense right bob
okay uh
mickey so if i'm looking at this
correctly
that at the with the um
the shortage in
21 that we have now
reduced the quote-unquote
surplus in 22 to 23
844 correct that's right
so we're starting out at 23 8 44.
yep yep so if we carry that balance
forward representative
to how we're going to start with fiscal
22 with that
it's essentially the same situation for
revenue base revenues are bumped up a
little bit
um i think this is related to just
hopefully
more people on the road more people the
plan for the next two years versus the
last two
more fuel will be consumed and more road
toll will be paid on that
um so we should see a bump in revenue
we've got our department of safety
appropriations there's a couple of
things going on in fiscal 22.
first on line 13 oops
on line 13 back in 2018
when we had a general fund surplus one
of the uses for
uh i believe it was a 20 million dollar
appropriation
was a general fund appropriation to the
department of transportation for
bridge work for red list bridge projects
i think it's been identified there's 8.1
million dollars
remaining in that appropriation and the
governor's budget
recommends lapsing that remaining
appropriation right into the highway
fund
to help balance the highway fund so that
one time
adjustment of revenue you will see that
in house bill 2
and that essentially helps the bottom
line of the highway fund by 8.1 million
dollars
another uh thing to point out here on in
fiscal 22
is the department of transportation's
draw appropriations off the highway fund
so you see how last year or current year
rather 230
fiscal 23 232 and it's way down in
fiscal 201
22 and if you recall the department
talked about having some federal money
available
that they were able to supplant in
operations to the tune of about 42
million dollars i believe it was
so when we look at the highway
operations accounting unit
in the budget document the big budget
document
highway funds are way down and there's a
federal
fund plug in there because of some
available federal dollars
uh that were uh pandemic related i
believe
to um help run or help
operate transportation systems so that
is a big help to the bottom line of the
highway fund otherwise you'd have a 41
million dollar
uh higher transportation appropriation
here which of course would affect your
bottom line accordingly so
that's why dot is so much lower in this
middle year
is related to that
mickey is that money from
the december
uh relief bill i believe it is but i can
confirm
i i know we'll have uh the department in
later this week
to confirm that but i i it's money
that's already been
approved it's not an anticipation of
something to be improved
okay so so is is this money going in the
budget
or is it going to come in through fiscal
and just
it's in the budget so it's in house bill
one
or it will be in house well it's in the
governor's recommended budget documents
so it wouldn't be something accepted
through fiscal it would be budgeted
okay thank you uh tom you have a
question
uh yes thank you i i just is that
is that shown on this document
oh so the 41 million dollars
yeah is it yes well the fed yeah that
federal money is that
is that somewhere within these numbers
uh it's not it the money
doesn't actually go to the highway fund
it just reduces how much highway fund
has to be used so
when you look at this line represented
you see that the dot transportation
or the dot appropriation goes from 230
million down to 182
back to 232. back to where you see it
let me if i can hear because you can see
it right in the budget
you skip it here we go
so if you look at the highway
maintenance bureau this is one of the
largest accounting units of highway
funds
at the department so their highway funds
you can see on this line here i don't
know if you can see that well
that's fine um go from 66 million
dollars this year
to 22 million dollars next year and
federal funds go from zero
to 41 million that's that's where you
see it
in this accounting unit so it really
reduces the draw from highway funds in
this year because there's federal funds
in their place
well that shows up right there thank you
representative heath you have a question
yes thank you madam chair
um so in the event that
more funds um from the federal
government come in
specific to um covid
will we be appraised that because that
right now with the governor's executive
order he has
pretty much authority over all of that
and we don't
get an accounting of that how would we
find out how it might impact our budget
one way or the other
um was that question for me yes
uh so so if if funds are accepted
uh federal funds accepted and budgeted
through the executive order
i believe those are reported to fiscal
and we can ask for that information
from the departments as we go through
this process uh an option while
the budget is being worked on is to
actually add those appropriations to
house bill one
you know that can still be done
throughout this process if there's a we
know we're gonna get this federal money
you know or um you know the more
traditional way would have been
you know outside of the budget process
to accept those dollars through fiscal
so
there's there's a few options i don't
really know what the course of action
would be
should money become available from
washington during this process
all right thank you uh representative
heath
if you if you remember from our uh
discussion
with uh commissioner edelblue he had
mentioned that there was
an additional 157 million dollars
that had come into doe
yes on one of the whatever
uh grants yes yeah yes
whatever okay yes let me let me get my
piece of paper here
yeah under s or two and so um
it appears that
doe has chosen not to put that in the
budget
okay yeah okay and so
whereas d.o.t chose to put that in the
budget so
i don't know if there's i don't think
there's any consistency
across the various uh
departments oh thank you madam chance if
i can ask
one more question um i remember i was
actually working at the department
in 2008 when we had the era money
and during that time we used
um about 200 million i believe of that
money to uh balance our adequacy because
we
back then we're in a a big hole um
so what i'm here what i think i'm
hearing you say
is that commissioner edelblue has
chosen not to use any of those
federal dollars that come under the
authority of the department of ed
to go into the state money that we send
to school districts
i know i know that school districts are
getting allocations that go
directly to them um so that that we
can't
do anything about that that that has to
go to them
but the funds that go to the department
of ed can't be used
otherwise other unless the commissioner
accepts that fund to be used in a
different way
i don't know if i'm making any sense uh
yeah i
you're making sense
but only if you've spent a million years
working on education funding
the real key here is and i don't know
the answer to this
and we can talk a little bit more to doe
about it
but whether there is specific guidance
from the federal government as to how
those dollars can be spent
and they may not be able to be spent for
things that we would like to spend them
for and i
yeah i also saw a report
that showed um the fact that a lot
i think it was i don't remember what the
figure was
but a lot of money that has been sent to
the school districts
that has not been spent yet and so
it's um you know it's a real balancing
act
uh as to um you know
how do we how do we handle this
go ahead i'm sorry if i could just add
um i
actually had a meeting with commissioner
edelblut in the manchester school
district
just about that because i was concerned
because i had been working with caitlin
to see about the sec
the second round of esser money coming
in from manchester
and and we learned that um they had not
drawn down very much money but then we
found out that they had a huge
technology order that had been delayed
and
that's why the money was and i think
that's happening across our state
but i think um more more importantly my
my big concern and hope
maybe is that if new dollars come in
with new federal dollars that we will
have some authority
to help in ultimately
balancing our state general funds budget
with some federal funds is is what my
hope is to help us out
and i don't know if i'm just being too
optimistic about that
yeah part of part of the concern uh is
that just like the 62 million that was
distributed this year
um you know and went out and explained
that it was one time money
for you know hard
you know things that you didn't have to
replace every year
and you know school boards made
decisions and that's the that's the real
one of the real problems that we have
and i
you know i'm all for local control but
it also
throws a big monkey wrench into
what the state can and cannot do so
i'm glad that transportation has decided
to do this
so mickey you want to
talk to us about the rest of this mess
yeah well there's not a whole lot else
to get into super
detail with um it's just that year would
end with
49 million dollars on a budgetary basis
in the highway fund
we kind of do the same thing again carry
it forward to start 23
based on our expected revenues
and budgeted appropriations as of right
now in the governor's recommended budget
these are the 16 million budgetary
balance
if we want to show our liabilities and
receivables the
position the net position is really a
negative for the highway fund
and i will get like i said i will get a
memo or something some explanation from
the comptroller's office and from the
department uh
to just so we're more informed on the
impacts of
balancing the highway fund on a
budgetary versus a gap basis
just so that'll help make your decisions
as you move forward
yeah i think that will be uh extremely
helpful
to us and it's and i you know it is the
highway fund
that's that's the uh that's the uh the
real problem so
okay uh can we take a five-minute break
and then we'll uh press on to
what we may think is in
hb2 okay
five minutes
as soon as bob returns
we'll uh go ahead and uh
chris i'm so happy that you're here
um i would uh i would like to say that
uh i'm not real happy about what ways
and means is done to
us and i know you don't have a lot of
influence in that
but something's got to give
i'm just staffing for the ways and means
so i do what they ask me to do
yeah that's no excuse you know that
thanks for adding us on to the mailing
list by the way
uh not a pro not a problem um are you
getting the revenue focus
as a committee
from i get i get it in services
uh represent murray you haven't received
the revenue focus from administrative
services
i don't believe so okay i'll
i'll ask them to add the um finance
committee as well
seems like we were getting a last one
committee was what happened
last session the finance committee was
on
actually the ways and means committee
wasn't so
so they got i think they got ways and
means on this time and took you guys off
so i'll make sure you get that
that's actually i i would suggest
probably a better tool to look at than
the daily report that i would send out
starting on the 20th
because it actually provides a little
bit more information in terms of why
some of your revenues might be up or
down for the month
and then gives you a um a year-to-date
information
as well um but happy to keep you um you
know on the
daily revenues we do just uh i know you
guys get a lot of emails so that's why i
don't
um chase it well we appreciate it
yep i agree thank you
welcome back and um
mickey if you would uh like to begin
our tentative
hb2 stuff okay so please i think mickey
has
warned us significantly that
um you know what what actually happens
with the final version is
what becomes our starting point and not
necessarily
what we have here and i'm sure that
as soon as hb2 is available that
lba will
send it to us uh either through the mail
or
ups or whatever fedex
or courier service yeah i think we'll
definitely get a hard copy
to you you know it's a little lengthy of
a document of course so
we'll send those out once we get them
printed
and and representative you're right in
that i'm going to stay super high level
so we did get back when the governor's
budget came out a transmission from the
governor's office with trailer bill
language
per the law's requirement which it goes
to the office of legislative services
and they start you know working their
magic to turn it into a
in the proper format references and all
that of house bill 2.
so i'll go over today with some of the
topics that
um we saw in the draft i'm not going to
get into any detail really
because i know that there was just some
clarifications back and forth still with
the governor's office and ols so i don't
want to be
super confident on something and tell
you about it from the draft document
then it comes out different with the
introduced bill so um
some of this will be repetitive with
stuff we already know about
so first with education funding i
believe the only change that we're going
to have there
is relative to an adjustment to the
free reduced lunch population for
determining adequate education grants
the specifics of that i think will be
slightly different than the bill
um that that's in that's going to pass
over from the senate
as far as just straight up using prior
year counts i think there's going to be
a formula for determining the adjustment
we'll
should be able to go through that
wednesday with the department because
they would have been involved with
developing the budget terry number
that's in house bill 1.
the public school infrastructure fund
the transfer from the education trust
fund to that
dedicated fund will be in house bill 2.
um
we saw it on this the surplus document
the snapshot we went through earlier the
15 million dollars a year so it'll be up
to
the division to support change delete
whatever
um but whatever change we make to that
would be a house bill 2 amendment
we heard friday an awful lot about the
proposal to form
the new hampshire college and university
system board of trustees and explore
a consolidation of the two systems of
unification
we will see all the details of at least
what's going to be proposed legislated
this session and what the charge would
be for that
board of trustees moving forward all the
specifics of course
all this would be in house bill 2. we
saw a little bit of the house bill one
change just the structure of the budget
merging those two into one
agency so to speak and one accounting
unit for their block appropriation
but most of the work and the decision
making would be in house bill 2
for for this
yes representative heath you have a
question yes
going back to the merger um i've been
trying to figure out what the difference
was um in the merger year
and it looks like there's um a total
reduction
in the amount of money going to both
well i don't know how it's going to go
but do you have the exact figure of how
much that reduction is
oh um well i can show you the page from
uh
the budget and we can maybe do a what
page is that
my grab it here hopefully let's see
i can't ask man i'm not sure
yeah page uh one two nine five
where you'll see the the appropriations
all right
and then just the one thing to remember
when when looking at those
i think you can see my screen here i'll
maybe i can
the the amounts for um
20 fiscal 20 the university system
included nine million dollars one-time
money for the nursing
program yeah and the community college
included
i want to say 3.2 million dollars of
one-time money for uh
it really i can't remember the specifics
so that first year includes some
one-time money when you're looking at
the four years across the board just
just wanted to point that out
all right thank you
i think uh ripping up petri
i'm sorry representative petry
not a problem uh thank you
um right donny uh can you tell me what
the
chancellor's uh budget is for the
university system
um i can get that information for you i
don't i don't know off the top of my
head
um that that doesn't appear in the
the state or house bill one of course so
i'd have to reach out to
uh kathy provencher and she can get us
the details on that for you
right could you make that all inclusive
yep
thank you
and that was just for usnh or
yeah well you can compare the two it
wouldn't wouldn't hurt to have the uh
community college system also
and uh just a comment uh you're one
awesome individual agreed
so moving on uh scholarship programs i
think we're going to see some
recommendations to
the existing state scholarship programs
as well as the development of the
workforce
student debt relief program for those
who have been on finance
you know if you remember from last
session this was something that came in
house bill 2
to finance from the governor's office a
similar plan
it ultimately ended up not being in the
house budget and ended up
being debated quite a bit in the senate
but ultimately didn't happen two years
ago
uh so this will be something that we
will bring in the
mat the experts on these scholarship
programs
so we'll have the unique program the
endowment the direct
allocation programs the governor's
scholarship program is under that
advisory board
as well as well as really moving forward
with the new student debt relief
proposal so
again none of this should affect general
or head or education trust funds in any
way
this would be the governor's scholarship
program
is a general funded program but i don't
think that's being
changed in any way uh with this proposal
um
but just to be aware of that program and
that that's in the treasury's budget so
that's why we don't see it in any
anything that we have here but that's a
general fund appropriation
but the unique program this uh workforce
debt relief program this would be from
that
the fidelity accounts assessment fees
the management fees that the state
collects
that's a restricted source of revenue
that's
currently used for that endowment and
scholarship program and this just talks
about
spreading that money out to other uses
too the mainly the
workforce development student debt
relief program
so moving on we talked this morning with
the highway surplus statement of the
uh redless bridge appropriation lapse of
the highway fund as a way to prop up the
highway fund so we will see that in
house bill 2.
so if you want to change that in any way
um
amend it agree with it delete it uh this
you'll see this change in house bill 2
and then we'll recognize it on
the surplus statement representative
murray you have a question
yeah thank you um is this
does this lapse have to happen or could
it stay uh could we consider
to say you know i'm not proposing this
but um keep the eight million and work
on those red listed bridges
so currently that 20 million original
appropriation
is non-lapsing and continually
appropriated
so if you left it there it would be
available for the department to carry
out the original purpose of that
so we have a decision to make there and
we could get dot's input on how they
could best manage that fund or
the money that's in
the only thing just uh obviously any
change to that would affect
the amount available for the highway
fund just to remember but yes
yep thank you uh
representative heath did you have no
okay uh the last significant section of
house bill 2 from the draft that we saw
was relative to establishing the
bodyboard and dash
board cam fund which um
again i don't want to speak to too many
specifics and i did put an amount in
here and i don't i think it's going to
remain
but there was an initial general fund
appropriation um
to fund this program which essentially
would be a matching program for local
law enforcement agencies to
uh buy uh replace operate
body warrant and dash cam systems with
their department
representative bucco you had a question
yes thank you madam chair in the last
budget
we approved um dash cameras
for all the state police cruisers um
i asked the commissioner about that but
i wasn't clear on his answer because he
said that we didn't do that so
did they just not not institute the
program or what happened there
or do you know uh well i i don't know
the specifics
but we can get that information with our
follow-up with safety this week
i can tell you any amount that would
have been appropriated and not expended
would have lapsed back to the general
and highway funds so
whether they did all their cruisers none
something in between i'm not sure
um but we can talk to them about what
happened with those
appropriations in the current budget
thank you
okay i don't see any other question
i should have started off by saying that
i think this was the lightest load for
division two with house bill 2
i've seen in a while at least even for
an introduced version of the bill
those at least in the draft document
were the major impacts
as far as policy to work on and direct
budget impacts
there was many other sections that will
be assigned to us to review but
um don't really have a direct budget
impact
a material one um and i'll go through
them real quick
so the department of safety uh in the
current budget they have some
transfer authority language that allows
them with the approval of the
department of administrative services
budget office to transfer from some
class lines
that are otherwise restricted class
lines to transfer from
it was something granted to them two
years ago uh as a way to offer
flexibility
that they seem that they deem necessary
to uh manage their budget for the two
years
and it's something that the governor has
supported for this this biennium too so
um it'll be up to you to
review that section and whether or not
you want to give it to them it won't
have
an impact one way or another on spending
so
um it's really a policy decision a
finance policy decision
the mechanical licensing board we heard
from the department of safety that this
has been moved in this budget to the
office of professional licensure and
certification
that accounting unit is zeroed out in
safety and
you know it's transferred over to be a
division one budget to review now
and they will probably review the house
bill 2 section as well and give a thumbs
up or thumbs down on this it'll probably
be something assigned to them
generally whenever there's a transfer of
a unit or a function
when we assign division responsibilities
we usually give it to the
the accepting uh division so in this
case
division one will probably decide on
that but i did put this on here just so
you were aware of it because it was
something we had heard from the agency
about
uh mickey did you say that it was
already
in the budget in office of professional
licensure
i believe it is if you look at fire
safety
in safety that accounting unit zeroed
out and i believe it's uh
that money is now resides in office of
professional licensure those general
funds
so the only the only question on this
then
is um do we think it's a good idea
right to move it and that could be a
joint decision with
division one you know because they would
have to be yeah we want
oplc our professional licensure to take
this on and
division two to be okay with you know
sending that
uh function over over there so but in
the budget that how you have it before
you house bill 2 and house bill 1 will
have it so the money and the function is
no longer at safety okay
for those of you that i know probably
tom is aware of this
but uh we had been trying to move the
mechanical licensing board
over for years and um
it was uh hotly opposed by
safety but it appears they have uh
changed their mind so i'm
i'm real happy about that
uh the next item um there is a section
relative
to radio equipment
procurement really purchasing and
outfitting radio across state agencies
uh we'll we'll hear a little bit more
about this from the department but i
think the idea is that the department
would establish standards
with the department of administrative
services so
there's a little bit more uniformity
when it comes to this
across all state agencies versus each
state agency kind of
going on their own when it comes to
radio operations
i don't believe there's a direct budget
impact to that i don't think there's any
funding attributable to it but that's
that's one that i kind of just have with
an asterisk here that we just want to
double check with the department to see
if there is any direct or indirect
budget impact the last bullet for safety
i think is one we can ignore uh in the
early draft there was some capital
appropriation
uh lapses and repurposing within the
department of safety from the last
capital budget
my understanding is those sections are
not going to be in house bill 2
and they are going to be in house bill
so it will be up to public works and
highways to figure that out
it won't affect your house bill one or
two um and this is just a good example
of how
uh we get the draft of house bill too
early but that doesn't necessarily mean
this stuff's gonna be in house bill 2 is
introduced you know so
i think we can ignore that um but i'll
confirm with with the division once we
actually get house bill 2.
fish and game department mickey
i'm sorry chris you have a you have a
question or a comment
no i just wanted to comment on on that
um capital appropriation i know it's in
house bill 25 i worked with the
governor's office to
figure out where it really belonged so
they worked with ols to remove it from
house bill 2 and to put it in 25 so
you won't need to worry about that in
your division
thank you you're welcome
so fish and game department in the draft
document there was uh
a couple of sections relative to the
statutory
provisions around bear damage and this
the process for getting
fish and game state reimbursement for
the damage caused
uh i don't believe this has any impact
on
state general funds for sure uh
what we can hear from the department or
once we actually see the language maybe
you know we can figure out really what's
going on if it's budget
impact or just a policy thing that the
department has to be included in house
bill 2.
department of transportation again oh i
think we have a question
sorry i'm sorry rebson murray
i was looking at my paper and not at my
screen
i do the same thing um i just wanted to
go back and check
because dispatch moved or fish and games
dispatched emergency dispatch moves to
department of safety and um that's not
reflected in hb2 is that
why is why is that not here i guess just
it seems to be a change that's
notable but not necessarily going to
affect us fiscally
no it's a good question and um again the
draft didn't have anything that was like
explicit you know these functions move
or whatever
i think positions maybe in house bill 1
got transferred and the budget itself
can do those without needing a house
bill to change
but we can confirm that with the
departments to see if any
legislation is necessary to make that
change work but i didn't see anything
relative to that specifically in the in
the
draft document thank you
dot there's a few statues changed that
are
mostly policy in nature or when i say
they're not really going to directly
impact your appropriations i don't
believe
one was uh changing some of the criteria
relative to
civil liability for folks who damaged
the highway
in any of in any way as far as getting a
reimbursement or a replacement
charge to them or through insurance or
however
those are handled
i don't i don't think that would
necessarily be a revenue that we would
address or
it wouldn't impact anything like that
this would be just something dot has
identified
as a change that they wanted and rec and
requested as part of the
budget process and it's in was in the
draft document
similarly we currently have a law
relative to the disposal
of pro-c or the proceeds relative to the
disposal of
real estate purchase with uh highway or
turnpike funds
um it was silent i believe on federal
funds and
there's a section in here to
say what happens with the proceeds of a
sale
of a real estate highway-related real
estate that was acquired with federal
funds
lastly i noticed in the draft documents
some sections that just added some
definitions relative to unmanned
aircrafts
or drones um i didn't see anything
related to
anything direct to the budget with those
i think it was uh
some policy stuff added the department
identified they needed um
and again for the usual when we get the
department in to talk about these things
they can explain
why they're needed or what the impacts
are
uh mickey before you before you leave
that
is the transportation committee
responsible for all of this
or does some of it fall in public works
like the civil liability i mean i'm just
i i just want to know which chairman i
need to
um a good question i i would say
i would say i would say the first two i
mean just
would be public works and highway
perhaps and then the aeronautics related
stuff would be transportation committee
but
um maybe if might be one of the things
worth
sending to both the chairman and getting
their their comments on i'm not sure
and they could decide oh yeah we do this
or not i'm not sure to answer the
question only because it's
you know it's amending the law and so
we we really need some sort of input so
i'll tell you what
i'll make sure that i harass both
transportation and public works to get
me something back on this
and that has happened in the past what
we've done with finance is some of these
policy related sections that show up in
house bill 2
we'll get feedback from the policy
committee
you know on them uh i don't know if
that's the plan this time i think it's
just a little bit early we haven't even
seen the bill and divvied up the
sections yet by division to take that
next step of whether or not the policy
committees will be part of it but that's
definitely something i think
the committee as a whole will have to
figure out soon uh
representative wyler did send out a
an email to all of the um
committees on the areas that
in the draft would were
uh affecting them and asked for
um as for input so that has
that train has left the station okay
good and uh
obviously if there's additional things
that
uh that come out or whatever
we'll have to follow up on that okay
all right the uh the last
section and this is something that is a
reoccurring section
so kind of back what you were suggesting
before representative lin
as far as sections that appear in house
bill 2
over and over so the new hampshire
scholars program
uh has had language in-house bill 2 that
allows for the department of education
to accept grants gifts donations to fund
that function
um it was in the last house bill 2 but
it was for the biennium only
it's going to appear again and house
bill 2 is introduced
for this biennium as well if it's
something that the committee supports
i mean it could be codified you could
amend statute so it doesn't appear every
year you know in the trailer bill
and that's something we can discuss when
when we're going through these sections
representative heath you have a question
yes please
um actually two that i want to ask
um the first one was related to the new
hampshire scholars program
it's been zeroed out in the budget but
the line remains
i would like to see it continue my
understanding is
um from debbie scary i've been talking
with her
about the scholars program because i
know senator d'alessandro was very upset
about
it it its demise we thought it would be
eliminated
they're going to try and figure out some
way to keep it going
so is that what the intent is of that
statement
um and or would it be possible for us to
um contemplate maybe a small amount of
money that can go because it used to be
i believe 100 000 for each year of the
biennium
and now it's been um eliminated um
and that's up to the division so um if
you want to propose an amendment that
adds a
you know x dollars whatever you pick
into that line to keep that accounting
unit on
in the operating budget and then also
have the
house bill 2 section that enables
outside money to come in to fund it
that's that's up to you okay thank you
and my second question
is going back to the top
about the merger about between the
community college and the university
system
would it be possible and i don't know
the answer to this
to have a public hearing through finance
to get input from people about
what we're seeing um in house bill
2 um and in the budget just to get input
i feel like we haven't done due
diligence
in getting information about the merger
um so would it be possible is my
question
to have a public hearing with regard to
the merger mary
that that is certainly uh possible
um and i can do it for division two
since uh um the other folks have
a lot of other things to do obviously
our our meetings are open to the public
and i have um but i
i can certainly announce it for
one day shortly that um this will be
a public hearing and then the folks will
have to
um send in their you know whatever
through um uh yeah through the website
to uh to talk about it um
and i don't know how does the rest of
the committee think that this is a uh
a good idea can you just give me a
thumbs up or what
mickey i'm only i'm sorry i'm i haven't
don't see uh representative lin and
representative petrie do you
i do see them i see a thumbs up for
representative petry
okay represent are you on board
representative lynn
you know i guess my only question would
be i mean i
i don't really see a particular harm but
my only question would be
um is this something that um
we ought to we ought to sort of run up
the flagpole so to speak
and see how um leadership
feels about that i've i'm but i'm
you know i've that's i speak as a
newcomer who doesn't really know a lot
of the
ins and outs of the of how things work
so that that's just a question i have no
particular
you know view one way or the other on
whether we should hold it here
um basically under the old system when
we all
used to uh arrive in concord for
uh our discussions um
people that had interest in whatever we
were talking about
would be sitting in our
room and if there were questions or
comments
or thoughts they would be
expressed at that time although we
didn't
call it a public hearing and i'm not
sure that we will call this a public
hearing but
we'll call it something that indicates
that
that people should tune in and
ask their questions now the other thing
is is that sometime in late march
we will in fact be holding a
budget public hearing uh to
uh to hear from from
people and i'm not exactly sure when
that's going to be that'll be up
to uh representative
wyler but i do want to
uh oh thank you mickey i do want to um
you know i i don't know how i'm gonna
how i'm gonna phrase it but
i think this is such a a huge
change that folks need to be aware
of of what's going on and i mean
all of us you know if you
if you know people that are
current trustees past trustees
of either system
or if um
you know you you know kids that are
attending the schools
you know they may not they may not have
an opinion on that but
uh you know we we just need to i think
to get
a broad range of of what's
uh of what's happening and of course we
still really don't know
what uh what is um
the governor's uh what the language is
going to look like
and the language i think in this case is
going to be
uh key to whatever happens
thank you madam chair i just i miss the
input that we used to get from the
audience sitting with us
uh yes i do too and uh i have not
seen anyone raise their hand as a
participant
because i think it was it's clear
in my opening statement that that is
certainly
an option for for people but
i have not although i don't check it all
the time i do check it every
you know as we're finishing up things to
see if the
uh if anybody out there in uh zoom land
has
uh has any questions so
okay uh mickey i really want to thank
you
for what you did um
i think it gives us all a uh a clearer
picture
of of where we are
and uh and what's happening
and um although
i am disappointed in what ways and means
has
given us to work with that's what we
have to work with
uh we have no choice and so
um if we want to
fund certain things then we have to
realize
that we got to take it from some place
and um and uh
that's that's that's got to be the way
it is
so it's uh you know we can we can juggle
around
the money within the education trust
fund
uh but we can't create new money
unless someone has a money tree out back
that is still growing it's too cold up
here for me to have a money tree so
okay um i think that uh
our next meeting is wednesday
at uh 10 o'clock when we will be
talking to doe
in particular i think we were going to
focus on
adequate education is that correct
and um i do think that
uh one day shortly we'll need to go
through all of the division all of the
departments on more of a
line by line discussion
and uh so that uh where we're seeing
you know tran highway funds general
funds all of these things
we really need to to look at that
uh obviously a little more closely
than what we have and i also
if you do have a chance before
is d.o.t on thursday i think we have dot
friday safety okay
safety's thursday dot's friday so if you
have a chance to look through
what uh mickey sent us on d.o.t
i know that uh for those that have been
on finance
before that is a very detailed
explanation
and of what is what's going on in
uh ndot so we'll uh
we'll look forward to uh seeing everyone
at 10 o'clock on wednesday
thank you all thank you mickey take care
yeah thanks for joining us chris
and as always if anyone have any
questions that come to you later today
as you're looking through the stuff
just feel free to reach out
okay you can close her down thank you
thank you